for 500 years after the Reformation the
church is moving towards unity again
I'll discuss that today with Pedro bossa
hooba bishop for ecumenical relations in
the german lutheran church welcome
interview that's thank you you command
welcome viewers I'm Thomas palmas van
wuzzle rafa theater most bossa hooba for
the first time the head of the Catholic
Church Pope Francis celebrated Mass with
Lutheran's on reformation day I'm what
sense what did you think about that
peasant leaf does the Sun cause our
tickets this is a wonderful symbol of a
new ecumenical atmosphere and perhaps
it's a historical watershed I was a fool
not yaarana after 500 years of violence
and conflict a relationship of
substantial trust has developed between
denominations keep this gets we're
seeing this on an international level to
not just in Germany where the churches
get along and have experience in
promoting unity that pops the Pope and
the Lutheran World Federation are
worshipping together for me it's a sign
of hope that after a lengthy ice age
we're now seeing an ecumenical awakening
the community of pork gets Unger's Agnes
Martin Luther rebelled against greed the
churches in calc uble wealth and
hypocritical authorities Pope Francis
has made exactly the same criticism of
his own clergy in Rome and other
Catholic officials do you think Lutheran
Francis would get along nobody burns
wood fatah it probably hit it off well
and I think Luther would be quite
surprised that the same catholic church
that excommunicated him is now honoring
him in this way I think the themes that
motivate Pope Francis are the same ones
that motivated Martin Luther and those
are liberation social justice and a
religious message that people understand
what this gate I know that you support a
message that touches their hearts and
change a society I attack on d
gesellschaft I think Lutheran Francis
with see eye to eye bootiful cannon at a
home on Catholics and Protestants a move
closer together for example you and a
group of Catholic Bishops recently
visited the Holy Land another first so
what was that like a FOIA deutsche ella
smith Commission before we went I had
mixed feelings I wondered whether our
expectations were too high and whether
we could properly follow in the
footsteps of Jesus in the holy land but
it was quite moving for me to spend a
week traveling around with the Catholic
Bishops and senior officials of the
lutheran church in Germany we really
were pilgrims and that's something we
don't usually do together but as
possible we'll sit together at
conferences or as guests on TV talk
shows but during this trip we prayed and
held religious services together that
told us we had safety it was something
very new and it not only changed our
relationship that's what it gave our
churches a new perspective the sadness
notice vihodnih smitten and otha in that
we developed so much trust and openness
that I now have new confidence for the
future Fatah land on Sophia often hide
copaxone does admit guns no ads so fuzzy
top of the Knicks niaga shower the 500th
anniversary of the Reformation is an
occasion to finally discover how much
the major churches have in common it's
not so fearful mega minds I'm
cat-sitting course and killing so
feeling positive side but I certainly
hope so before indecent this year's
reformation day marks the church's 500th
anniversary celebration of Luther but
many young Germans have no idea what
reformation day is all about for them
October the 31st is Halloween does that
bother you I got me this for care to
what I really bother is the wrong word I
think it's sad but the way the church
conduct itself contributes to this
situation we have to be self-critical yo
Eggman I'm telesales Katusha settlin so
our society knows so little about its
traditions not just the ecclesiastical
ones but also our political and societal
traditions being equal he had either we
know so little about the principles of
personal responsibility and autonomy and
the freedom that our society values so
highly we as leaders of the church
should admit
we've done a poor job of conveying the
importance of the Reformation so it's no
wonder that a lot of people don't know
anything about it gets these you'll be
leah was fired so these anniversary
celebrations are a good opportunity to
get back to the basics and communicate
with people who no longer have a
relationship with the church that gets
the balls and once more I see a lot of
new interest in understanding our own
culture our own history and our own rice
what's the noise of Eden I also see new
opportunities for contact even among
people who were not raised as Lutheran's
a funky list via bluetooth feeds atul
gupta to interfere in the homeland of
the Reformation attendance at Lutheran
services is dwindling but it's
increasing in africa asia and the
americas what makes the lutheran church
so attractive there Thank You Think You
Can a practicing it slower doesn't
muirhead skirting off does problem I
think that many people believe that the
larger churches are established and have
nothing new to say but in societies that
are going through political and social
changes many people are encountering
religion for the first time and they
want to find out more about it Caitlin
dagens few noise and guns there are now
more Protestants in Africa than in north
america and europe combined but that
fact is not well known that's why it's
no kind on new planets congregations are
growing in Asia especially in Korea and
China and they're learning more about
what it means to live as a Lutheran
christian mission I don't why is a
custom tool salimos and unders it's and
each offer doesn't I hope we can learn
something from these churches and
breathe new life into the church here in
germany deutschland for twitter currency
test blog specifically could we learn
from that come on Dan Glover that's one
alpha and was doesn't we have to stop
taking it for granted that we as
established churches in Germany with our
reliance on Luther or Calvin or others
will survive intact through the
centuries with covino Olivia's and such
as I people demand to know why one
religion or another should interest them
def one can kind of eight amazing
mention one vision of a home we should
speak much more simply and effectively
about how people can find the answers
they seek in the churches I info and
FIFA gentlemen we should explain why
it makes sense to read the Bible it's a
beautiful book that answers questions
about the meaning of life hardly anyone
asks those questions anymore and few can
provide answers Isaiah Jeff Knox Ted
gosh laggard in button for your body
many people right now are alarmed about
globalization wars and terrorism people
seem to be longing for a sense of
community can't the churches step in
here and help them find it a flower son
does Ben give us a visor I think we do
benefit from this situation in the sense
that people are asking important
questions if we can no longer take peace
for granted even in Germany people will
want to find out how to build a peaceful
society that puts the Christian message
the message of Jesus back into view that
he bought jocular pusst you die it's not
so much the people are demanding a
church they're demanding existential and
essential truths essence yeah I don't
existence yet what can I do about the
violence I've experienced how can I find
some kind of healing where can I find
forgiveness on how can I put my life
back together what kind of helmet
important- labors under a vagina v if
I'm not successful do I still have value
as a human being people are asking these
questions today as they have for
centuries I own that I think we owe
these people some answers I think the
message is still fresh and new but
sometimes we need better packaging
lawyers dusty folk pop off your life off
leash them I wasn't it but there are a
number of major political issues that
people are concerned about they have no
solutions to these problems like the
dominance of financial capital around
the world widespread poverty and
reducing all aspects of life to an
economic bottom line shouldn't the
Lutheran Church take a page from Luther
and speak out more forcefully nail its
theses to the door so to speak maybe at
a Wall Street firm from y'all's garnish
I think that would be an excellent idea
I would join a group that would do that
as our problems that involve justice and
peace must be resolved collectively they
cannot be resolved by individuals you
can renew gemeinschaft lift bad for them
we all have to work together in there so
fit such to won't be latent in half but
not in today
world the countries of the northern
hemisphere are profiting from the
destruction of countries in the southern
hemisphere Nima it's killing this cannot
continue hamada to identify them it
definitely the situation has led to the
refugee crisis for example and this is
not a crisis caused by refugees it's a
crisis for our way of life is low but as
a scanning under ski that's the Stefan I
believe that the Protestant churches and
the Catholic Church as well must take a
clear stand on these issues see talking
you said we what motivates you on a
personal level because they are for you
I travel a lot and I see human suffering
all over the world I know that I lead an
unbelievably privileged life and
sometimes the contrast between how I
live and how they live is almost too
much to bear puzzle God is in mind movie
I will do everything in my power as
Bishop working in cooperation with the
church the World Council of Churches to
make sure we keep investigating these
situations and keep holding the
politicians accountable and when we find
a situation that's unacceptable will
condemn it that's when you put it is fun
for deletion I'm aveda oven fun we have
to commit ourselves does we untangled
was only fighter get the size that by
email we have to make changes in our
personal lives the church needs to carry
out internal reforms via we need to
limit climate change and promote world
peace with the other league you is
another soil and we must maximize our
ecumenical resources to promote justice
Siddiqui wanted cyclical ship coming
home at SWIC let's return to Luther the
Lutheran Church said it doesn't want to
glorify him during this anniversary year
or present him simply as the founding
father of the church the church also
wants to point out his personal
weaknesses let's expand on that theme
I'm going to give you three in complete
sentences and I'd like you to finish
them number one Luther said that women
are hard control to that I would say
it's a gadda a devilish quickly realizes
he's right and that's a good thing yeah
Luther didn't spend a lot of time
thinking about gender issues
you could say that in many ways he was a
macho man but at the same time he did
much to promote equality between men and
women he was a man of considerable
contrast if they come in if I weren't a
bishop I'd like to be deep so deep sea
diver why fund Amamiya I've always been
fascinated with marine biology I had to
make a choice biology or theology
obviously I chose the latter misty Lou
gigawatt looky blackton a heightened my
hope for this Luther anniversary year
would be far too fond Isom job this is
angles I would like to see it become a
major ecumenical event I would also like
to see our entire society realize how
much we can do if we work together pick
up Paige my boss ahuva thank you thank
you